reading third film of the franchise
decides you like the death star will
give you the mother probe that star
again it's just like Jason Voorhees that
Death Star hey the death star was a
horrible failure let's build another one
no I love Jim Henson as much as the next
person but this is where the Star Wars
creatures started to get that more
lovable fake plastic sheet look you know
for kids they're 101
spiral wrap penis head has a point
Java's looking we chunkier and realer in
1983 than the last time we saw which was
in 1997
also if Leia didn't choke him Jonah was
certainly gonna die from smoking green
swamp heroin and he's still frozen in
carbonite
thanks Threepio what could possibly come
over bastard Luke c-3po is too smart to
not understand what's going on this
scene suggests that the robots somehow
behave differently when put upside down
man that they have feeling in their feet
also hilariously these brands never even
touched the robot's feet despite all
that steam you see shooting out Tatooine
loves a different kind of superhero the
Heil Hitler spider-man the song Jedi
rocks also it was like Lucas was
wondering hmm how can I possibly turn
return to the Jedi into a bad movie
everyone here appears to be enjoying
this music and this dancing look I like
this movie a lot more than most but the
plan here was to send three waves of
troops droids then Leia Chewie then Luke
when Lucas Jedi enough to not really
need the help of any of the others makes
for good cinema sure but as a military
strategy it's kind of stupid considering
every single person Luke sends ahead of
him gets captured everyone else had to
lie their way in here but somehow Lando
is just king here already BAM deal with
it also sneaking around Jabba's palace
will require the removal of my mask
why does Jabba have windchimes at a
place where there is rarely wind also
any plan that involves sneaking into a
room with this many creatures sleeping
in it is a bad plan she may be a
princess and a Jedi without knowing it
but stealth is not one of Leah's strong
points as this scene proof futuristic
melting looks oddly like how melting
might look on an Atari 2600 I can't say
seems like one of the first things Leia
could have said han was don't say a word
silence is golden I really don't even
know why she'd bother keeping the mask
on since she was doing some highly
improper in Jabba's palace anyway
delicate escape plan has time for a
make-out session not only to Jabba catch
Leia rescuing Hall he was hiding behind
a curtain like he was expecting this I
agree that Leia is pretty hot but how
does Java a giant snail slash excrement
pile get turned on by human women climb
boss that has been chasing Han for years
immediately puts him in a Cell with his
right-hand man Chewie Jedi mind-trick is
the same in tutty's and English Master
Duke you're standing on even though
Threepio gets interrupted Luke ignores
the warning he might be standing on
something unsafe Luke tries to force
pull himself a blaster and Java somehow
beats him to the punch
but more importantly why does Luke try
to force pull a damn blaster does he not
have a lightsaber Jesus this is the
worst rescue plan ever I mean can you
imagine how short this fight would be if
Luke had his lightsaber with him can
Luke not Jedi mind trick this thing that
thing looks pretty weak-minded he's not
even trying to make him think this is
not the food I'm looking for Luke sticks
the bone in horizontally but it's a
perfect vertical jaw prop in the next
shot why is there any kind of electronic
door down in this dungeon just a what
people who think they've found a way to
escape
magic gate appears out of nowhere in
this sequence giving Luke the proper
gate X maakad and he needs Luke throws
the skull instead of just using the
Force to sling it you could argue that
Luke highly underused the fours in this
battle star wars succumbs to subliminal
ad placement and allows Joe Camel to
hawk cigarettes during the movie in his
belly you will find a new definition of
pain and suffering as you are slowly
digested over
luckily I'll die of hunger thirst any
number of things in just a few days so
the thousand years thing is overkill
unless I'm being fed and watered while
I'm down there thank God for the special
editions so I can have this shot of the
heard of programs to help set the
emotional stage for the Sarlacc scene
bar to d2 just stick close to Chewie and
Lando Han should be freaking out at the
mere mention of Lando the dude that sold
him out in the last movie because he got
sold out and then went to sleep and
literally just got up a few minutes ago
and it should still fucking hate Lando
Bri Han acts like Luke isn't the guy who
murdered the fucking Death Star
in order to fall into the pit of the
Sarlacc you must walk a plank first as
we soon see the plank becomes a perfect
way to ex machina this real quick this
takes forever and none of the bad guys
kill Luke while he's flipping around or
waiting for his lightsaber to fall in
his hands on the other end of this why
didn't Luke command that thing to come
to him faster
also I see the lightsaber was hidden
inside r2d2 because you assumed to be
better to have it now than back in Javas
lair where you could have smoked all the
fools in seconds gotcha
even the Tatooine Wilhelm's suffered
tragedy
none of these assholes can aim or shoot
at the same time it's kind of easy to
look like a Jedi Master when everyone
else sucks Boba Fett a skilled bounty
hunter can't aim either but that badass
bounty hunter goes out like a bitch I'm
surprised that Sarlacc tentacle didn't
shoot on first convenient multiple
electromagnets on random pirate ship
come in way Andy in the Empire Strikes
Back
han tells Luke that's two you owe me
junior but this is the first time Luke
has done anything to return the favor
and suddenly Han has flipped the math
where he owes lukewarm
when you're a regular a stormtrooper
when you hear this laughs don't you have
second thoughts then I am a Jedi I guess
all the other Jedi had to confront some
terrible extremely difficult evil to
become Jedi - huh is Darth Vader my
father arrest I need God cats out of the
bag and this asshole still won't tell
him the Darth Vader is his father
they're not ready for them for you oh
come on this is some nonsense here don't
you think it would have been better to
tell him like immediately and then he
could have gotten used to the idea
before his friends got in trouble how
does becoming a Jedi settle you in for
that Darth Vader is your father whopper
arguably the training would have been
smoother and you could have prevented
him from going so soon another you would
align Yoda survives just long enough to
tell Luke a whole bunch of he already
knew and then in his last breath finally
provides the mere setup - an important
bit of new knowledge he ceased to be
Anakin Skywalker and became Darth Vader
so you know symbolic technicalities
prevented me from telling you the real
truth you can see how my hands were tied
the good man who was your father was
destroyed so what I told you was true
from a certain point of view
okay now obi-wan is just being a dick it
was purposely misleading and he has the
gall to say well I told you the truth as
I knew it to be but you had to play a
game to which only I knew the rules for
it to be completely true also you didn't
know you were playing a game and oh by
the way your mom too but I was amazed
how strongly the force was with him I
took it upon myself to train him as a
Jedi it was actually quite gone who
noticed anakin specialness and took it
upon himself to train Anakin as a Jedi I
only took over that require I died but
you don't need to know about that right
now
you're on a need-to-know basis you must
face Darth Vader again when he left he
hadn't completed the training yet and
they told him not to face Vader
now he's back no more training than
before and now he has to face it but
honestly what else did they even need to
teach him they've said don't give in to
your anger and its many forms at least a
hundred times in the last two movies was
there an anger course coming was he Oda
gonna give him special instructor Bruce
Banner to help with all that
he spoke of is your twin sister I'll let
you fill in the blank since from my
arcane Jedi point of view Leia is your
bangable friend you didn't need to know
was your sister Leia as my sister 1983
audiences then went oh my god what an
amazing surprise this series just keep
you oh my god they kissed each other
several times in the series didn't they
while the fighters fly into the
superstructure and attempt to knock out
the main reactor Death Star has the same
weakness as the original Death Star you
know what needs an energy shield the
main reactor does we have stolen a small
Imperial shuttle stealing that's one
general count me in I'm with you two
where did this asshole come from and how
did he hear that does he even know what
he signed up for it could be at gangbang
for all he knows Lando looks confused
that he's in a room with giant
Millennium Falcon wallpaper yes my must
the Emperor gives Vader orders and then
immediately consults with two purple
dudes we've never seen before we're
never see again making me wonder if the
purple dudes are somehow above the
Emperor
shuttle tydirium transmit the clearance
code for shield passage hey isn't that
the ship that got stolen from our fleet
quiet you I'm endangering the mission I
shouldn't have come that's correct
is r2d2 gliding across thick indoor
floor right now even if there's a path
this guy's gonna have a hard time
gliding over a hilly muddy grassy land
isn't he gone down how many people does
that fucking thing hold I thought it was
just Luke and Han in that Jesus what a
storm troopers have different armor
everywhere they go it could be anything
to do with toys could it go for help
can't you radio it in yeah jam their
comlink all speeder bikes come standard
with communication jamming devices
instead of just lightsaber in this
dickhead
Luke jumps over the dickhead speeder
bike to take him out manually and much
more slowly than necessary yeah how can
I possibly avoid the Ewok haters wicked
is cool with me and I'm taking ass in
off just for how cute wicked is and you
can almost suck my furry ass if you have
a problem with that said that keep this
if he walks honor the reason Jar Jar
Binks exists even though chronologically
George are shot first
I mean came first want something to eat
Leia offers alien food to an end or moon
a night there's no stormtrooper alive
who could walk through this forest
without making a sound my son is with
them
you sure aren't you the Emperor wouldn't
you know he will come to me I have even
though I did not foresee that he was on
the moon right now but whatever in this
huge entire moon of Endor Luke just
happens to wander by Leah's discarded
helmet I'm afraid that our two senses
can find no trace of Princess Leia then
our two sensors aren't worth because she
was all over this joint just a little
bit ago and even Luke's faulty Jedi
spidey sense thinks you're all literal
deus ex market but I do believe they
think I am some sort of God they think
I'm some sort of God cliche it's against
my programming to impersonate a deity
what because it's lying you've lied
plenty of times in this series so if
it's specifically impersonating a deity
that is some very specific programming
did that he won't just speak Jabba's
name three times but some Candyman right
there the Ewoks are basically furry Lost
Boys only with fewer assholes among them
too many minutes of II want cultural
misunderstanding bullshit
Threepio tell them they must be set free
but it's against his programming right
he can't impersonate a deity therefore
he cannot give orders to the Ewoks
QED tell them if they don't do as you
wish you'll become angry and use your
magic and here he is again pretending to
be a deity what the hell was all that
nonsense before they got dragged here if
Luke can do this why can't he untie the
ropes Princess Leia c-3po story of Star
Wars highlights how very little there is
to return to the Jedi
mainly because there's time for this all
that stuff that happens in Jedi could
have been settled in an hour but Jabba
the Hutt lasts nearly 40 minutes and
then they sandwich that he walks into
this thing for even more exciting
waiting around she died
leah has memories of natalie portman
force is strong in my family father has
it I have it my sister has it
damn that took two minutes to get around
to the crux of this story and he still
doesn't even come out and say it it's
you
and no somehow I've always known even
during the scene I can't tell you this
secret will make you explode hon did you
tell Luke is that who you could tell I
Star Wars General Hospital the Death
Star still has the same progress it did
at the beginning of the movie these
assholes aren't doing jack to build the
rest of it wait
earlier Luke told Leia he could feel
that Vader was on this very moon right
now but then this scene suggests a derp
is only just now arriving on this very
moon the emperor has been expecting you
I know father mother father this
dialogue is stilted I see you have
constructed a new lightsaber your skills
are complete when did the lightsaber
weaving class take place on digamma or
do you just know how to make one after
various force related activities in the
you are powerful as the emperor has
foreseen
there is never a realistic moment that
we see where Luke becomes a badass Jedi
at the end of empire he was more mature
he'd seen some but not quite awesome yet
this movie has apparently set a whole
year after the last one although it's
incredible to think that they waited
that long to save huh I guess in the
meantime obi-wan conducted ghost ops
with Luke but the movie wants him to be
awesome
right now with no hint of the journey
that got him to this place oh crap
prepare to jump into hyperspace on my
mark all right stand by meet what you're
standing by and he hasn't given any
order but you still instantly jump your
ass to hyperspace
jeanna command motherfucker do you speak
it it takes 75% of the guards to go
after this one
Ewok apparently the door opens when you
shoot it everything that has transpired
has done so according to my design
really even the destruction of the first
Death Star even Luke and Leia's birth it
was I who had the alliance to know the
location of the shield generator and
part of that plan was hoping they would
steal one of your ships so they could
make it to Endor how did you make that
possible or knew it would happen they
very nearly weren't allowed in because
Vader since Luke was on the ship also
why not have to shield generators one
you tell the Alliance about on that
secret just in case the rebels however
unlikely managed to destroy the one that
you've let them know exists that's maybe
a little unfair of me to bring up but
seems like more could have been done
with this plan to ensure the rope will
defeat rather than just get blasted
red leader standing by Rey leader
standing by
remember the first movie when you love
this well swallow a couple spoonfuls
more none of them can it just Drake me
down with it give in - I really don't
understand how he suddenly becomes a bad
person if he kills Vader in the Emperor
the story requires them to die if the
rebels are to win so if Luke can't turn
Vader's he's supposed to kill these guys
with warm feelings any reason why our
heroes are merely prisoners and not shot
to death - you definitely only saw one
in addition to having terrible aim
stormtroopers are also known for being
easily taken down by a pack of basically
living teddy bears can arrows really
pierce stormtrooper armor good god man
being hit by these things at the speed
and falling this kind of distance would
not hurt anyone once on the ground the
stormtrooper is cuddled to death oh come
on this is useless you might as well be
dropping hopes and dreams on the walkers
I mean how do ordinary rocks drop from
30 feet not just bounce the fuck off a
storm for uniform this battle is all the
stupid so cute I can't prove it because
I'm too lazy to just open the other
movie in check but I think this is
recycled Death Star firing footage from
a new hope and if it's not it's close
enough to be sinned anyway han like ham
the widest ons best friend mispronounce
his name han and Leia somehow find cover
in this position last time you shut the
fucking door and it opened now you need
r2 to open the door and although the
Empire still uses r2 compatible hardware
well I suppose I got hardwired this
thing
since this Death Star beam could only
fire in a straight line
shouldn't all the big rebel ships just
start flying around in circles no fleet
is lost
yeah these scenes are tedious basically
the Emperor invited Luke here so that he
could narrate the rebels doom to him all
time and repeat things over and over is
there a path to the dark side through
boredom let the Ewok who is without sin
cast the first stone damn why didn't
they do this in the first place rather
than trying that hang glider rock drop
bullshit from earlier the flaws of a
robotic Walker are exposed yet again han
cops a feel after Leia gets shot in the
arm you
your aggressive feelings boy let the
heat flow through you I still don't know
how this takes you to the dark side but
I guess the force is unforgiving when it
comes to killing absolute evil you have
no recourse after you've aggressively
killed your father if only you can find
a nicer way will be one of you will
there is giving obi-wan all the credit
again does Yoda not make any ripples in
the force a little fight you sighs I
mean any more than I already have it's
tough squats to help first off
apparently there are no identification
protocols with the Empire anymore after
that first movie so this works also how
are there any empire guys left you had a
whole army outside waiting for them and
you still have enough for three squads
who were previously sitting around just
jacking off even as he walks begin
winning as the Emperor not realized that
taunting makes somebody not want to do
what you want them to do this shield
generator is a super huge satellite
thing so while Luke was down here why
couldn't he turn the satellite in a
different direction and maybe even break
it using the force Ella magneto could do
it in expend first class you're gonna
tell me Luke couldn't do it force
lightning is introduced as a power ten
minutes from the end of the third movie
Skywalker you will die then kill him
already
no with the rules set so strictly for
Luke so that he can't kill these Sith
Lords without turning to the dark side
with his only hope being able to turn
Vader somehow I can't imagine a scenario
that's luckier other than finding out
that Leia is adopted just as luckily
there's a place in this room where Vader
can let gravity decide this that said
the real question is why is there a ship
sighs path to get to the power generator
the arrogance and stupidity of the
Empire is amazing hey that doesn't look
like James Earl Jones Anakin Skywalker
does not disappear all Jedi like as
obi-wan did and Yoda did and he's
clearly going to heaven because he shows
up later during the Ewok Jubilee Luke
who had no idea what else was going on
manages to make peace with his dying
father and board a shuttle just in time
to barely escape these goddamn flames
from the Death Star explosion every one
of the heroes are a bunch of lucky
bastards did it take forever to get to
the middle of this thing with lots of
twisty passages and why does the Death
Star not immediately explode like it did
the first time I'm sure Luke wasn't on
that thing blue
he wasn't I can tell because Luke told
me I had force power and now I can use
that power without any training you love
him don't you
yes Leia answers this question is if she
actually told Han about Luke being her
brother earlier even though she kept it
a secret for no reason it's my profit
Hans probably also thinking of the see
Digital cheering George Lucas doesn't
resist the temptation to the dark side
and defiantly puts Jar Jar Binks in the
original trilogy
[Music]
maybe I don't like the ewoks like I did
when I was a kid and this new music
isn't all that bad
but the up Nam song was a pretty fitting
ending and yet now it's changed to
something more special not only do you
get to go to heaven Anakin you get to be
your young prequel self again while
obi-wan and Yoda stay oldish ever since
cinemasins began the most requested
thing has been TV since and now it's a
reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio out I'm endangering the
mission I shouldn't have come I'm
getting what I deserve I'm reaping what
I saw
[Music]
remember only you can prevent forest
fires
[Music]
Arizona moon keep shining from the
desert sky up
[Music]
use your aggressive feelings boy let the
hate flow through you give real money of
hid shut up search your feelings father
you can't do this
I feel the conflict within you let go of
your hate we are the United States
government we don't do that sort of
thing